what's going on people in this video
we're about to break down episode 23 of
attack on titan season 4 in which
annie's full backstory was revealed and
captain levi finally makes a return to
the series
today i'll be explaining all the small
details you might have missed including
exactly how connie tricked falcon into
coming along with him and how in this
episode armin failed an important
responsibility that levi had given him
years earlier
before we get into it though this video
is sponsored by dragon city which is a
free-to-play mobile game available on
android and ios in the game there are
literally thousands of dragons to
collect including a particular series of
dragon called the titans although not
the kind of titans you might be used to
seeing on this channel you can breed 2
dragons together to create new ones
hatch them and feed them so that they
evolve and you can even train your
dragon to make them more powerful on top
of that the game has pvp modes where you
can challenge your friends in combat and
fight against other dragon trainers not
to mention mini games like the ones on
screen where you can claim daily prizes
by collecting food golden gems you can
customize your own city to reach new
levels and along the way you might
discover dragons based of popular
content creators including the sidemen
dragon the george not found dragon and
many many others if you download the
game by clicking my special link in the
description then you'll get a free
starter pack only available to new users
which includes 30 000 gold 15 000 food
plus the very rare snowdrift dragon this
offer is available for a limited time so
be sure to check out the link and thanks
again to dragon city for sponsoring
today's video
okay so episode 23 begins in stowis but
nowadays thanks to aaron it's looking a
lot different
because nobody on parodies knew that he
was planning to destroy all three walls
it meant that many civilians in
stowaways had their homes crushed
without warning and a ton of people died
in the fallout in this scene hitch and a
couple other mps pull an injured woman
out the rubble and as the bodies pile up
some of the civilians start to question
whether aaron's actions were worth the
sacrifice
on one side you have people who see
aaron as a kind of villain for killing
his own people whereas on the other side
you have those who believe that these
deaths are justified to stop them all
from being wiped out by mali
as violence breaks out between the
civilians hitch then returns to hq to
gather some resources to deal with it
but as she enters the building she
notices this trail of liquid the trail
directly leads out from the basement
where the female titan's crystal has
been locked away for years and this was
a deliberate trap that annie had set
by not covering her track she was hoping
that someone would follow the trail at
which point she'd ambush them steal
their clothes and sneak out of town what
she wasn't expecting was that the person
to come through this door would be hitch
as these two have a history together not
only as roommates in the mps but also
because hitch was the main person who
was looking after her crystal the whole
time
now in this moment annie is easily
overpowered by her former roommate since
she's pretty weak having not moved a
muscle in four years this enabled hitch
to pin her down without much problem but
the real issue here is that the female
tyner had already cut herself with this
special ring the blade inside this ring
is what she typically uses to transform
and so in theory she could have become a
titan right then and blown up hq
of course there was the chance that she
didn't have the energy to do this in her
weakened state but it wasn't a risk that
hitch was willing to take with the power
of the titans being so unpredictable it
was safer for everyone in the building
if she just did what any said and that's
how the two of them end up in the
stables the plan here is that hitch
would quietly take the female titan
outside of the district and during this
conversation we got an insight into what
it's like to live inside a crystal
the way annie describes it it's like her
state of partial consciousness where she
could hear what's happening around her
but other than that it was basically
like a dark dream all that time the only
company she had was amis news updates
and hitch ranting about men so it is a
miracle that annie hasn't turned out any
crazier than she used to be
as they leave town we see more of the
carnage as people mourn their dead
relatives and hitch makes an interesting
observation that her only meaningful
work has been cleaning up after the
destruction generally speaking that
statement is probably true for most mps
since their jobs usually don't involve
improving humanity in fact for most of
their existence they were used by the
king to prevent humanity from
progressing for that reason you can see
why hitch would find some meaning in
helping people to rebuild after these
disasters and the first time she had to
do it was after aaron and annie tore up
stoics
moving on they then have an honest
discussion about annie's motivations and
this added a ton of context to our
actions in the first season to start
things off we find out that annie was
abandoned as a baby by her real parents
since just like reina she was the result
of an affair between an aldian and a
regular human because of that she was
adopted by mr leinhardt who himself was
an alien from a foreign country he knew
that by raising annie to become a
warrior it would give him the title of
honorary marlian and all the benefits
that come with that and so during her
childhood he aggressively trained her in
the martial arts from his homeland
the endless practicing and physical
abuse made it so that she eventually saw
no value in any life whether it was her
own life the lives of animals or the
lives of the soldiers she had to kill
from her perspective none of it had any
meaning and as a consequence she also
didn't care about saving the world like
the other warrior candidates did
anyway once she grew up strong enough
she beat up mr leinhardt to repay him
for all the suffering he put her through
and this beat down was so bad that he
received permanent damage to his knee
explaining why he's usually seen with a
walking stick
after then graduating to become a fully
fledged warrior she was then chosen for
the invasion of paradise and the morning
of her deployment is when mr leinhardt
dropped to his knees and apologized for
everything he'd done this moment here is
a more detailed version of this
flashback from the first season as it
does a better job of conveying just how
devastated he was although he'd never
shown his true feelings until this
moment he did in fact view annie as his
real daughter and to him the title of
honorary malian didn't mean anything if
she never returned from the island it
was only once she heard this speech and
looked into his eyes that she realized
how much he cared and from that point
onwards it became her singular
motivation to make it back home alive
this motivation has been demonstrated
many times for example when marcel was
eating it was annie who suggested they
should go back home and while stomping
out rainer she made it clear how
desperate she was to return to mali
alive
then a few years later when they were
inside the walls it was annie again who
suggested they should go back without
completing their mission
she's also the warrior who arguably put
in the most work into locating the
founder so they could go home and those
tears when she was captured was because
she wasn't able to fulfill her promise
now in the present day annie accepts
that her previous view on life having no
value was wrong and that all the deaths
she caused wasn't really justified
however she did still say that she'd do
everything the same way if it meant she
could get back to her dad
switching over to the internment zone in
liberio we then see one of the most
realistic aspects of the rumbling which
is that these eldians have to actually
try and convince regular people that
they're all about to be trampled given
that aaron's declaration was only heard
by subjects of ymir the malian guards
have no way of verifying what the crowd
is telling them and the head guard seems
to believe this is all some kind of
elaborate alien conspiracy as a result
the guards start to round up everyone
including annie's dad and reina's mother
and the other warrior parents which
reinforces the idea that being honorary
marlians means nothing in the eyes of
actual malians with his hands behind his
head mr leonhardt remembers his daughter
promising to return and the reason this
gives him strength is because he needs
to stay alive himself if he's ever going
to see her again he's always believed
that annie is still out there but
obviously if these guys keep him in the
internment zone then they'll all be
crushed by the rumbling in a few hours
because of this he had to do something
to get out of the situation and in this
scene miscellanet turns around to face
the guard followed by the immediate
sound of shots being fired the anime
then transitions very nicely back to the
island where instructor shardus
overhears the sound of flux gunfire
at this particular time pretty much all
the surviving characters in shiganshina
some were inside this fort with the
aegis now establishing their control the
aegis made it very clear earlier in the
season that someone of the old
leadership like chardis was disposable
to them which is exactly why these
cadets want to get him out of there as
soon as possible there's no doubt that
his safety will be in danger if he
sticks around but instead his priority
is making sure that his students can
survive in this new world the aegis are
creating which is the reason why he let
them beat him up charlize knew that
someone like him was never going to make
it regardless of what happened but if
his cadets joined the yagaris then
they'll survive until one day they can
start a revolution
this ties into what hanus was saying
last season in that when one group takes
over from another it's only a matter of
time until the cycle of revolution
eventually repeats again
now in the changing room armin is
getting ready for a trip to ragako
village as he's determined to try and
stop connie from feeding falco to his
mother his aim in doing this isn't
simply to save falco as i'm pretty sure
those two have never had a conversation
but rather he's doing this to earn
gabby's trust if gabi trusts armin then
it might be possible for the scouts to
use that trust to ease their conflict
with reiner and peak who are both still
somewhere on the island as he goes to
leave mikasa asks him what they should
do about eren and this is when armin
loses it at her possibly for the first
time ever the reason he snaps is because
of all the things going on right now
aaron is dead last when it comes to what
they should be dealing with for example
nobody knows where levi and hanji are
annie is back the volunteers that have
helped them for years are now in trouble
and there's an unknown number of
casualties on the island on top of that
the queen is possibly in danger as right
now they have no idea what the aegir is
planned to do with her
with all that going on no one is in any
position to be thinking about aaron
hence why armin lost his composure at
the question he then goes on to riley
point out that commander aaron wouldn't
have reacted in the same way and follows
this by admitting that he wasn't the one
who levi should have saved
if we flash back to 4 years ago no one
was realistically expecting the
commander to be replaced but one thing
levi asked of armin was that he didn't
make himself or anyone else regret the
choice that was meant to be his
responsibility going forward but now we
can say that it's a responsibility that
he's definitely failed in crisis
situations like this evan always remain
level-headed even when other people were
losing it and this distinction between
the two is why armin feels the way he
does
anyhow as armin lee's mikasa notices her
scarf is missing and the last time we
saw it she left it alone in this room
with her number one stalker
things then briefly switched to outside
where nicolo and the brass family say
their last goodbyes to gabby since it's
unclear if they'll ever see the warrior
candidate again as we know gabby and
armin's current mission is to make it to
ragako village before falco gets eaten
but beyond that we know her motivation
is to stop aaron from rumbling the world
therefore there's a decent chance that
her time on parodies might be coming to
an end very soon which is why this whole
interaction felt very final
back inside the four we see the
volunteers have been rounded up just
like flock wanted in the last episode
and this moment helps to explain why
aaron left him in charge of the yagaris
ten months ago we already knew that
aaron and elena had a secret meeting
where she told him about the
euthanization plan and flock is the one
who enabled that meeting to happen
soon after this aaron revealed to flock
that he planned to betray zeke and ever
since then flock has been gathering
allies which is why the aegis was so
strong in numbers and well organized as
soon as the revolution began
with the rumbling now underway pretty
much everything has gone the way they
intended but being the psycho that he is
flock mocks the volunteers for their
homelands being destroyed a lot of these
volunteers are from countries that were
invaded by mali and they helped paradise
because they thought it would weaken the
malians and therefore benefit their own
nations that's why this guy was so angry
at flock since all the volunteers have
been betrayed and it's why he was never
going to submit to the jaegris sadly
this stance is what got him executed i
mean pretty brutally as well and this
was done to show the other volunteers
what's going to happen to them if they
don't comply
remember at this moment in time the
island still quite literally has no
functioning government so flux mission
is to bring order to parities and a part
of that involves wiping out anyone who
would resent the yagurus being in charge
now when it comes to jon this is a
really tricky situation for him since on
the one hand aaron and flock have
created a situation where he can finally
stop fighting and he can live a comfy
life in the interior just like he used
to talk about on the other hand he knows
that this treatment of the volunteers
and the destruction of their homelands
is objectively wrong which explains this
very guilty look with onyankapon no
matter what happens it's inevitable that
in the near future jean will have to
make a difficult choice either he can
ignore his morals and allow the aegis to
continue or he can take some kind of
stand against them which would mean
sacrificing his life of luxury in the
new aldian empire
as the scene ends mikasa asks flock
about what happened to levi and hanji
and he tries to deceive her by saying
that zeke killed them don't get me wrong
he likely does believe that these two
are dead by now but by saying it in this
way he's making it seem like the yeagers
had nothing to do with it in reality
flock saw levi as a threat to the aegris
and wanted him to be killed evidenced by
the fact that he was gonna kill him
before hunji jumps in the river by
leaving out that information flock is
trying to avoid conflict with these two
since like i said one of his main goals
is to minimize the amount of people who
oppose the aegiris
elsewhere on the island connie and falca
were heading towards ragako on horseback
and the two main things we need to
understand from this interaction is that
number one falco has no idea he's
inherited the draw titan in the past
we've seen that new time shifters
usually forget the events surrounding
how they got their power and in falco's
case the last thing he remembers is
being with colton gabby this means that
he doesn't know his brother is dead he
doesn't know galliard is dead and he
also doesn't seem to be aware of the
rumbling
point number two is that connie took
advantage of this memory loss by making
up a fake story and now the young
warrior believes that he's being taken
to a hospital the credits then finished
with falco feeling like he's seen connie
somewhere before and this is referring
to the airship where the warrior
candidates definitely would have seen
him in particular there was one moment
where he dramatically opened the door to
announce sasha's death and gabby and
falca were both in the room at that time
things then move over to general mcgath
and the cart titan who watch on as the
remaining malian airships leave them
behind with the rumbling marching
towards the continent these ships are
going to warn everyone about what's
happening but mcgath acknowledges
there's nothing anyone can actually do
to stop the destruction the car titan
then reacts as hanji approaches them
from behind and this is the first time
we've seen the commander since the first
episode of part two in that time she's
managed to steal a horse and fix up
captain levi who is very much alive
despite not being in the best shape
now you might be wondering what hanji
would gain from approaching pekin mcgath
in this way and the answer is that at
this moment both sides sort of want to
achieve the same thing
to be more specific levi wants to kill
zeke which is something the general has
tried to do several times and hanji
doesn't agree with aaron destroying all
life on the planet which is something
that no malian wants to happen by
combining their forces it would make
achieving those goals at least a bit
more plausible and this potential
alliance should be explored in more
detail next week
anyway people that was my breakdown for
episode 23 of attack on titan season 4
and if it helped you to understand the
episode in any way then i'd appreciate
if you dropped a like and let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
also don't forget to check out this
special link in the description to
download dragon city and get your free
rewards
thanks for watching the video as always
and until the next one peace out